most of my aikido life it didn't happen
in tai chi and yo but most my keto life
i just want to get on with the aikido i
don't want all this other
added things but i mean i realized that
without the added things you don't
actually find either
so you're actually rushing to get into a
tunnel
because you think the tunnel has the
answer the problem is you don't know how
long the tunnel is because most tunnels
are dark
so i
i didn't listen basically to people
who give me wisdom about aikido or you
should try this
you should do that all that technique's
wrong you need to do this
i agreed with them for their
satisfaction
knowing that i was agreeing making them
happy
because there's more conflict if you
start saying i don't agree with that
because then you've got to start saying
why you don't agree
and i decided that um
if i want to talk to paul about
something and he has a different opinion
we can never ever ever prove who's right
we might both put up really concrete
ideas and answers but someone else would
come in and i agree with him
and then somebody else well actually i
agree with scentsy
so so when you actually accept that if
none of us can be correct
it's better then to just search
on your own or this is the how how i
thought about it
some of you might have bought my second
book and it said keeping the
keep in the eyes of a child you know
keeping the mind of a child
so and i've talked about this before
when you're quite young what are you
going to do when you grow up then what
job do you want to do
you're young you know that's the last
thing in your mind that you actually
want to start
discussing what you're going to do when
you grow up
but the but the adult world pressurizes
some pressurizers
and then you get to work and then you
know if you do well you'll get on
so so life is a pressure
and an aikido i found
part the other art i found aikido is the
only thing
through divorce near bankruptcy
the world coming in coving i can still
go and do i could go
i can still pretend to be superman in my
own little world you know
here i am at 70 and it fascinates me
today as much as ever
i was saying to john last night if i had
a big whiteboard and i said to everybody
right i know i haven't warned you but
i'd like you to write on the board
why you do like you know what it does
for you
i don't even know if the whiteboard
would be big enough to put all the
different
things but i'm asking you that question
now without a whiteboard i'm asking you
what do you think aikido does for you
most of you will actually go up
can you give me a little bit a minute to
think about that one
i mean who do you all understand what
i'm saying
it's difficult to actually put a a
definite
oh dear what one thing why oh
so there's so many different aspects
to what makes it work
without without what shabash was talking
about
without what alex was
showing flexibility without what
jenny was doing about you know like she
said i mean i've got terrible knees
but if you can't squat
you can't do aikido because it has to be
a technique from
head to toe in all directions
but some gymnasts will be able to
perform more than others
with the ken there's a lot less we can
do
than the joe so we will spend a little
time today
but these are cuts that i'm showing you
have just
movement and we're going to have a
short break and then we're going to go
as we go
and i'm going to try and show you the
difference between structure
of just basic form of partisan basic
form
and trying to reach um
expansion and how
you start realizing what coke you is